Merhaba
bugün sizlere kendi hikayemi Anlatmaya
çalışacağım hiç karanlıkta yürüdünüz mü
ya da karanlıkta yürümeye çalıştınız mı
etrafınızda hiçbir şey yok Bir tane ışık
bile yok ama gitmek istiyorsunuz Çünkü
merak ediyorsunuz İşte benim hayat
hikayem Aslında bu bilmediğim bir yolda
kendi içimdeki ışıkla beraber hayata
tutundum ve futbolla tanıştım
Aslında baktığımızda kendi çocukluğumu
çok da toplumun beklentilerini
karşılamayan standart olmayan bir
çocukluk geçirdim Çünkü bana Uyumsuz
dediler
nedeni ne gelince Normalde kız
çocuklarından beklentiler
genelde tatlı olurlar Bebekler ile
oynarlar Ben ise Karate Kit izleyip
odama kapanıp acaba bu hareketi bende
yapabilir miyim Ne başlayan Daha sonra
da annemi tamamen bilinçsiz ama enerjimi
atsın Allah aşkına artık şehirden çık
deyip halk oyunları
yapmaya çalışan bir kız çocuğuydum
toplumda maalesef şöyle şeyler var kız
çocuğu pembe Giyer doğar doğmaz elinde
bir bebek veririz neden geleceğe
hazırlıyoruz ardından da çocuk Aman Ayşe
olmasın kapacak
ütü masaları inanılmaz fırınlar veririz
kıza ve onu öyle hazırlarız erkek
çocuğuna da baktığınız zaman mavi
giydiririz ve Sen erkeksin at arada
noktayı siz lütfen tamamlayın Bunların
hepsi gelecek deriz ve erkek dediğin
gibi gerçekten Evet ya bunların hepsine
Bana sahip olabilirim ki
Bu tamamen toplumsal bir yanılsama
maalesef Çünkü insanlar istediği gibi
hareket edebilmeyi keşfediyorlar
ve merakıyla beraber o karate kit'teki
hareketleri yapacağım derken
Bence harika gidiyordu ta ki ablamın
üstünde bir iki hareket denedim ondan
sonra annemden gelen bir terlik ve
karate Hayatım burada son buldu
dünya günleri kovaladı baktım sporla çok
içeyim ve enerjimi bir şekilde burada
atabiliyorum o zaman beden eğitimi
okumalıyım dedim spor bilimlerini tercih
ettim
spor bilimlerinde okurken de aslında
futbol oynamak istiyorum Bir türlü
futbol oynayacak yer bulamıyorum futbol
oynamayı istemenin Nedeni de şu benim
babam otobüs şoförü çok fazla uzun
seyahatler yapıyor bana zaman ayırmıyor
ama ben babamla zaman geçirmek istiyorum
küçücük başımda dedim ki sen benim ne
zaman ayırmıyorsun O zaman ben senin
zamanın içine girerim ve babamın halı
saha maçlarına gitmeye başladı önce
İzleyici olarak daha sonra oyuncu olarak
kendimi ispat ettim sonra da onuncu
olsun olmasın Necla'yı getirmiyor musun
Halı sahaya da adama ihtiyacımız var
deyip çağırılan eleman oldu
Sonrasında da
üniversitedeyken Ersun Yanal
ankaragücü'nde çalışıyor ve diyor ki
arkadaşlarına Ya bana bir tane kadın
antrenör bulun ama hareket Eğitimi ve
koordinasyonla ilgili de uzmanlığı olsun
farklı bir şey deneyeceğim tabii ki
farklı olunca arkadaşlarım da hemen yani
o yüzden sen seversin böyle şeyleri
denemek ister misin diyor
daha hayatında şöyle bir şey var bana
yeter ki bir dene diyeyim mutlaka
Denemeye çalışırım ama başarısız olurmuş
olsun ama aklından silerim mutlaka
denerim benim için harika olur Ben zaten
futbol oynamayı çok seven bir insandım
ama maalesef Türkiye'de kadın futbolu
kapanmış ve ben lisanslı bir şekilde
oynayamadım benim için güzel bir anı
Olur gelirim tabii dedim Bir hafta
boyunca Ersun Yanal ve ekibiyle beraber
futbola özgü hareketleri hareket Eğitimi
ve koordinasyona çevirdik bir hafta
sonra takımın karşısına çıktım futbolla
ilgisi olanlar çok iyi bilir popüler
futbolcular karşınızda 30 tane erkek var
büyük hata Short Giymişim
Dizlerimin titremesini engelleyemiyorum
Dizler sürekli birbirine çarpıyor Herkes
bana gülüyor olsun dedim Bunu da
Başaracaksın 5 dakika sonra biraz daha
kendimi toparladım bir baktım
Antrenmandan keyif alıyorum
baktım futbolcular da keyif almaya
başlamış süper acaba devam ettirebilir
miyim derken antrenman bitti
Aysun Hoca beni yanına çağırdı sen de
dedi bence bir antrenörlük potansiyeli
var Sen bu işi sevdin mi Evet hocam
sevdim hoşuma gitti bence devam
etmelisin ama dedi Tek eksiğim var nedir
dedim bir tane Kronometre uzattı bak
dedi Her antrenörü mutlaka bir tane
kronometresi olur al bunu dedi Bundan
sonra antrenörlük hayatına başlar neden
antrenörlük hayatının başlangıcının
başlangıcını yaptım sonra arkasından
Gençlerbirliği
Gençlerbirliği'ne gittim
inanılmaz derecede çalışıyorum
süper okullarında çalışıyorum geliyorum
akademikinde çalışıyorum profesyonel
takıma çıkıyorum O da yetmiyor Ersun
Hoca her akşam beni okulda hangi dersi
gördüysem onunla ilgili sınav yapıyor
hepsinin Cevabını veriyorum ve sahaya
çıkıyorum
E böyle devam ederken
canım akrabalarım aileme baskı yapmaya
başlıyor Ben Hoca torunu Hacı kızıyım bu
arada
O yüzden giydiğimize yediğimize
içtiğimizde çok dikkat ederiz diyorlar
kendime babama ya bu kızla bak sıkıntı
olacak fena değil Eli yüzü düzgün kız
bunu harcıyorsunuz 30 tane erkeğin önüne
çıkıyor yani laf olacak evde kalacak bak
Selami yanlış yapıyorsun diyor şimdi
annem babam bana çaktırma böyle
çalışıyor her seferinde şöyle derler ya
sen unuttumsun hani bu işe Döner mi
Bilmiyorum diyorum yani kimse bu işi
daha önce yapmamış Bilmiyorum bakacağız
Hani güzel de gidiyor Sonra annem babam
şeye karar vermişler ya bu kızı Biz
şimdiye kadar tutabildik mi tutamadık
yapsın akrabaları da şunu demişler
Necla'nın arkasındayız bir şeyler
deniyor başarılı olur başarısız olur
Konuşmak istemiyorsanız konuşmayın
arkadaşlar sıkıntı değil diyorlar ve
bana aksettirmiyorlar durumu
ve ben Böylelikle gençlerle çalışmaya
devam ediyorum arkasından arkamda görmüş
olduğunuz Vestel Manisa spora gidiyorum
ve Vestel Manisa sporda da profesyonel
takımda devam ettiriyorum her şey harika
ilk yarı Mükemmel gidiyor ilk yarı Çünkü
beslenme hatırlarsanız Ersun Hoca ile
devreyi birinci kapattık şöyle bir şey
oldu bu kız Uğurlu ayağını attı uğur
getirdi İnanılmaz muhteşem Necla İyi ki
geldim Bizim takımımızdasın harika işler
oluyor dediler
kendimi gerçekten bir şey zannettim yani
o ara Evet ya Ben uğurluyum attığım yer
Bereket akıyor falan yapıyorum
ikinci devre aşağı doğru gitmeye başladı
İşler sonra da şöyle söylentiler çıktı
al dedi gemiyi alırsan bir kadın olacağı
Hani hocam en sonda Ersun hocaya şunu
dediler
olmaz gemide kadın var dikkat dağıtıyor
nasıl dikkat dağıtıyor
konsantrasyonda bozuyor futbolcuların
inanılmaz söylenmeye başladılar
şimdi rica ediyorum şu fotoğrafı bir kez
daha bakar mısınız
bu kıyafet Sizce futbol takımındaki bir
antrenörün giyebileceği bir kıyafet mi
değil bu kıyafeti giymeyi mi 3 tane
nedeni var bir malzemeci sorumlusu beni
sevmiyor
2 takıma ait değilim 3 kadından futbol
antrenörü olmaz ha bir tane daha ekleyip
erkek bedeni olduğu için bütün
kıyafetler giydiğim zaman da çuval gibi
oluyor doğal olarak da kendi
kıyafetlerimi tercih ediyorum buradan
bütün gençlere tavsiyemdir bir spor
kulübünde çalışıyorsanız iki kişiye çok
dikkat edeceksiniz iletişiminizi iyi
kuracaksınız birincisi masör ikincisi
malzeme sorumlusu Bunlar sizi severse
kralsınız Bunlar sizi sevmezse rezil
olursunuz İşte benim aslında yaşadığım
süreç bu
ve ben gemideki kadın olarak uğursuz
ilan edildi ve Aslında hikaye orada
başladı Neden uğursuzum ben bu işi
yapmak istiyorum antrenörlük vasıflarıma
da Sahibi neden uğursuzum kadın olmam
neden bu kadar önemli her ne kadar
antrenmanı her çıktığında cinsiyetimin
ütülemeye çalışsam da ister istemez
kadınım kadın olarak da var olmak
istiyorum şimdi hikayemi Bundan
sonrasını size futbola özgü terimlerle
Anlatmaya çalışacağım futbolda 3 tane
adam var 1 Bölge 2 bölge ve 3 bölge Ben
Futbol antrenörlüğünü ilk Başladığım
zaman birinci bölgedeydim asla tartılı
antrenör olmadı
kulübe adım atıyorum Ben de aynı zamanda
başlayan biri erkek var o antrenör Hoca
ben Necla Hanım hoş geldiniz Ben de
hocayım Sen hanımsın Peki tamam sonra
başladım ispat döngüsüne bir erkek 5
saat çalışıyorsa Ben 10 saat çalışıyorum
bir erkek iki antrenmana çıkıyorsa Ben 4
antrenmana çıkıyorum 22 sene sonra
kadına milli takım teknik direktörü oldu
22 sene bir erkek bu süreyi 11 senede
alabiliyor
iki katı çalışmam gerekti olsun
ulaştığım yerden dolayı da son derece
mutluyum sonra bu kadar fazla ispat
döngüsünü o kadar fazla kafayı takmıştım
ki iletişim kurmayı Unuttum çünkü Çok
çalışmalıyım futbolu Özge her şeyi
öğrenmeliyim daha da iyi işler
yapmalıyım ki yanımdaki arkadaşlar eşit
pozisyona gelebileyim
buna takılırken Aslında herkesle de
çatışmaya başladığımı anladım Çünkü
herkesle kavga ediyordum kulüpte Hayır
bu böyle değil bence bunu böyle
yapmalıyız Sen yanlış biliyorsun deyip
Sürekli insanlarla çatışınca en sonunda
direktörüm geldi dedi ki herkesle
çatışıyorsun Sorun sende olabilir mi Sen
de bir sıkıntı var İki gün eve kapandı
düşündüm Evet o kadar fazla kendimi
ispat etmeye o kadar fazla aslında bu
tarihsel kısır döngünün içinde
bocalamışım ki
bu futbol topuna tarihte bir tane erkek
değil de bir kadın bulsaydı ve vursaydı
şu anda erkek Egemen bir spor branşı
yerine kadın Egemen bir spor branşını
izliyor ve takip ediyor olacaktık
tamamen bir tarihsel kısır döngü ve ben
bu kısır döngünün içerisinde iletişim
kurarak oyunu 1 bölgeden ikinci bölgeyi
aktarmam gerektiğini fark ettim ve ondan
sonra işler biraz daha değişti çok
kıymetlidir Oğuz Çetin bir gün telefon
etti kadın milli takımında bir yapılanma
var bu yapılanmada sende bir kadın
antrenör olarak olabilir misin dedi
benim için Tabii ki inanılmaz değişik
bir duygu
İstanbul'a geldim bir alışveriş
merkezinde Üstümü değiştirdim gömleğimi
giydim kalem eteğimi giydim görüşmeye
gittim Beylerbeyi'nin koskocaman beyaz
bir demir kapısı vardı eskiden o kapının
önünde durdum şimdi dedim 2 kapı
erkeklerle çalıştım bir şeyleri ispat
ettin artık kendi Hem cinslerimde çok
mutlu bir süreç geçireceğim
milli takımda başladım çalışmaya
Bir gördüm ki gemideki tek kadın ben
değilim
benim birlikte çalışmaya çalıştığım
kadın oyuncuların hepsi aslında gemideki
uğursuz toplum tarafından kabul
görmüyorlar Çünkü toplum onlara diyor ki
erkek işi yapamazsın elinin hamuruyla
git voleybolu oyna diyor
Aslında o dikdörtgen kareyi her oyuncum
girdiğinde kendini ispat ediyor kendi
içindeki gücü hissediyor yapmak
istediğin şeyi yapıyor
bunu anladım ki çok çalışmamız lazım
demek ki bir ispat döngüsü tekrar
başlıyor Ama bu sefer çatışmayacağım bu
sefer iletişim yoluna gitmeliyim dedim
ve çok kıymetlidir Şimdi de iki tanesi
Burada iki arkadaşlarımla beraber Yola
Baş Koyduk gece gündüz çalıştık kadın
milli takımını nerelere getirebiliriz
hangi projeleri yaparız diye tek tek
kapı çaldı
babası kızı okula göndermek istemiyor
futbol oynaması asla yok kapı kapı
Çaldık abiciğim Gel bak ben sana bir
anlatayım futbol oynayınca bacaklarını
çarpık olmuyor fena değil İdare eder Kız
daha iyi olacak Fiziksel anlamda bak
milli takıma gitmesi de daha kolay bu
kızın hem para da kazanır beden eğitimi
öğretmeni olacak sürekli ikna sürecine
girdik ve geldiğimiz noktaya
baktığımızda Aslında çok kıymetli
oyuncularımı görüyorsunuz ve biz artık
ikinci bölgede top çeviren birbiriyle
paslaşan kendini yol arkadaşı bulabilen
bir seviyeye gelmiş olduk
Peki Oyun Bitti mi
Oyun bitmedi onun ne zaman bitecek 3
bölgede Artık tamamen kaldığımız zaman
bitecek üçüncü bölgede artık gole
ulaştığımız gol atmamız gereken sürekli
Varyasyon yaptığımız bölgedeyiz Şimdi de
size onun en büyük ispatı Bu kızlar
neden bu bayrak altında çok iyi şeyler
yapmak istiyor Bu kızlar inandığında ve
destek olduğunda neler yapabilir onu
göstermek istiyorum haydi Ebru Ebru
geliyor Ebru
Harikasın Ebru 3-2 kazanıyoruz rakibi
İsrail ve puanımızı yediye yükseltiyoruz
[Alkış]
son kez bir şey söylemek istiyorum
Kendimi Bildim Bileli hep Uyumsuz dedim
ya Ne olursunuz şuna inanıyorum uyumlu
olup dünyayı yaşamaktansa Uyumsuz olup
dünyayı değiştirmeyi tercih ederim çok
teşekkür
[Müzik]